[Music]
is this your late night debut M yes this
my late night yeah you're
CH yeah uh I'm not just uh buttering
your bread my friend well thank you you
wouldn't know it you're such a smooth
and mellow mother oh is I I feel I feel
like I get that credit sometimes for
being mellow but I'm actually like just
really quietly filled with rage like
like everyone and I drink alone so you
know do have this thing when uh I uh I
call call it mirror drinking uh it's
when I do shots alone in front of my
bedroom mirror while telling myself how
awesome I
am sort of uh just kind of gearing up
for the night if I'm going to go out or
just stay in uh but that is uh that is
what I
do sometimes it just gets it's too good
sometimes things get a little dark and
so I stay in uh after that but yeah I do
I like you get shitfaced you do Tony
Robbins esque affirmations yeah
affirmations to myself yeah do you drink
I drink I used to drink on a budget and
so I would always I would always have a
flask with me and uh when it was really
cheap I would just buy a PBR and I would
Chase shots of my flask with the PBR
Class Act Right that's not I thought you
were going to say you decanted the PBR
into
the no nobody at paps yeah no no one at
PBR expects that let's do a speed round
do you want to play Speed round
absolutely this is real fun uh movie
Monsters or True Crime uh True Crime
yep okay pay for drinks or sneak a flask
you did that one mhm mhm put it in my
shoe sure yeah how is that one of the
questions was that actually on it yeah
that's a wonderful Serendipity question
number three pay for drinks or sneak a
flask doesn't say filled with PBR but
it's implied okay Bren Sullivan
everybody one more time for my friend
that's a great show that's our show and
it was great thank you Robert Rodriguez
good night thank you
[Music]
br